better give your choice an ice machine
[Music]
but I'm suing some human I respect if
engineers will be fast enough I can hear
em again here in the st. petersburg
apartment building you can find tatiana
zoo voltina better known as the green
screen grandma a retired engineer
tatiana has attracted a following
creating some unique content for YouTube
Tatiana's channel has almost 30,000
subscribers and over 2 and a half
million views the previous had become
really linear the conditional
Catholicism surprising because Tatiana
is completely self-taught namacarya
vigilant the latest release a tire swing
fair coz they usually fall in a bikini
for Muslim dolly
he studied and Buddhist art school
master guru soon appears programa
premier proof Couture excavator please
voice to montage what a take images in
here Mitchell Abramovich make a little
profit on the CD once she graduated from
puppetry pianist channel really took off
there was one video in particular that
really propelled her to the national
stage domina hidden a memento with a
devotee Lavinia Kasasa toast poem
totally legitimate Oh trollee Catherine
yes Neela Maria would you want a novel
article by bicycle Express motor it will
cater all on a chair admissions the
statistical risk level required a
spelling just as cute as M canal
whatever billing annual the frania
hedonistic it's very large and growing
audience at the end of the team yourself
at the star yes Oscar honest opinion
youtuber in business piccata bridge
alone a previous connection dominance
you know spectacle
malinka Monica Michelle knows your
widget a baby star now but you gotta be
famous don't you the writing was
advocating is crawling back at you
[Music]